WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS.
SHE LOGGED ROLLS ON A PENCIL.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
WE ARE 18 MONTHS AWAY AND THE
REPUBLICANS ALREADY HAVE THEIR
GUY.
THE DEMS ARE NARROWING THEIR
CHOICES DOWN.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RESPONDS,
EVERY TIME WE TRY TO HELP THE
UNDERDOG, YOU CALL IT SOCIALISM.
WHEN ACTUALLY SOCIALISM IS ALL
ABOUT CREATING UNDERDOGS.
THE DEMS HAVE THE ENDS AND NONE
OF THE MEANS.
AT THE END OF EVERY FALSE
PROMISE IS ALWAYS SOAK THE RICH
UNTIL THERE ARE NO RICH PEOPLE
LEFT EXCEPT THEIR RICH FRIENDS
AND IT NEVER WORKS BECAUSE EVEN
IN A FREE MARKET YOU CAN'T
BANKROLL A LEFT-WING MONEY PIT.
VENEZUELA WAS RICH ONCE UPON A
TIME.
PANIC HASN'T HIT THE DEMS YET
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T LEARNED
ANYTHING FROM 2016.
THE HEALTHIEST WHY IT OF AMERICA
HATES POLITICIANS AND THE MEDIA
THAT SELECTS THEM.
IT'S HEALTHY PERSPECTIVE FOR IT
OPENS THE DOOR TO CANDIDATES WHO
DON'T FIT INTO BOXES OR CHANGE
THEIR ACCIDENT OR FAKE, PHONY
CADENCES.
THE DEMS COULD USE ONE OF THESE.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
RUNWAY IS LIKE AN ICE SKATING
RINK AND THE FIRST STEP I SAID
YOU KNOW THIS SUCKER IS
SLIPPERY.
I THINK IT WAS BLOATED BY
DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S A TRAP.
I'M TELLING YOU.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I WENT DOWN,
THE PRESS WOULD HAVE A FIELD DAY
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS.
AS I STAND HERE FLOATING AROUND
ON A PIECE OF ICE.
THIS IS GREAT.
STUPID PEOPLE DID THIS ONE.
NO, NO.
OR BRILLIANT.
>> Greg: LAUGH ALL YOU WANT
BUT IT'S A POLITICAL PHENOMENON.
THE OLD POLITICIAN OF THE
1970s, TRUMP WAS A PUNK ROCKER
WHO CLEARED THE FIELD.
WILL THE DEMS FIND THEIR OWN
RAMON AND THEIR OWN JOHNNY
ROTTEN?
DON'T ASK THE DEMS.
THEY HAVE NOT A CLUE.
THE BEST THING PROBABLY TODAY IS
BETO ON THE VIDEO.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
LET'S GO TO THAT.
>> MORE BECAUSE YOU'RE A MAN.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE ARE
THINGS I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO
DO IN MY LIFE THAT OTHERS
CANNOT.
>> WOULD YOU SAY THOSE ARE
MISTAKES, BEING ON THE COVER OF
"VANITY FAIR?"
IT LOOKS ELITIST?
>> IT REINFORCES THE PERCEPTION
OF PRIVILEGE.
>> Greg: DANA, THERE'S
PROBABLY NOTHING LESS ATTRACTIVE
THAN THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK BIDEN'S ENTRY
INTO THE RACE HAS SCRAMBLED THE
WHOLE THING.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE SUPERSTARS
FOR A COUPLE WEEKS AT LEAST
SAYING WAIT, NOW I'M WAY DOWN IN
THE POLLS.
NOT GETTING ANY TRACTION.
LAWSON STAFFERS, RECONVENED,
REBOOT, REVAMP.
HE GOES ON THERE AND I KIND OF
LIKED IT WHEN HE WAS ARROGANT
GUY WAVING HIS ARMS AROUND.
STANDING ON TABLES.
THAT WAS A LOT MORE APPEALING
THAN AGREEING THAT --
>> Greg: HE LOOKS SMALL.
>> Dana: IT HAS TAKEN
SOMETHING AWAY FROM HIM.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE REMOVED
SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: MY PUPPY JUST HAD
THAT PROCEDURE AND HE WEARS THE
CONE OF SHAME.
MAYBE BETO NEEDS THAT.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHO IS
TRYING TO APPEAL TO WITH THE
ANSWER.
MAYBE IT'S "THE VIEW" AUDIENCE.
I LIKED IT WHEN HE WAS BEING
HIMSELF AND NOW HE FEELS
OVERMANAGED.
>> IT REINFORCES THIS IDEA THAT
POLITICIANS WILL SAY WHATEVER
THEY HAVE TO DEPENDING ON THE
AUDIENCE.
IT WAS FOR "THE VIEW" AUDIENCE,
THAT'S NOT THE AUDIENCE THAT'S
GOING TO GET YOU THE VOTES EARLY
IN THE POLLS.
IT IS SO INAUTHENTIC.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AUTHENTIC
COOL GUY WITH A SKATEBOARD AND
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE IS
COMPLETELY PHONY.
>> Greg: THE EXPERIMENT WHERE
THEY PUT TRUMP IN THAT SEAT AND
ASKED HIM THAT QUESTION.
>> Jesse: IF JOY BEHAR CAN GET
HIM TO CHANGE HIS POSITION, WHAT
YOU THINK CHINA IS GOING TO DO?
CHINA IS GOING TO SAY "TAKE THAT
BACK."
AND HE SAY OKAY.
>> Juan: WHEN HE SAID THAT, HE
IS SPEAKING TO "THE VIEW"
AUDIENCE.
THERE WAS CRITICISM AS I RECALL
FROM KAMALA HARRIS AND OTHERS
THAT SAID THIS GUY SHOWS UP AND
HE GETS ON THE COVER OF
"VANITY FAIR" ."
BECAUSE HE'S THE FLAVOR OF THE
DAY AND HE IS HANDSOME AND HE
LOOKS LIKE KENNEDY.
BUT THEN WHAT'S REALLY HELD HIM
DOWN, HIS NUMBERS HAVE NOT GONE
OUT.
I THINK PART OF IT IS PEOPLE
STARTED TO SEE HIM AS THE RICH
KID, BIG KID WHO ADA CAR
ACCIDENT LEFT THE SCENE AND ALL
THE REST.
>> Katie: LIKE A KENNEDY.
>> Juan: HAS LOTS OF MONEY AND
HIS WIFE IS A BILLIONAIRE
APPARENTLY.
I THINK IT HAS CHANGE THE
PERCEPTION SO I THINK HE IS
SPEAKING TO AMERICAN WOMEN WHEN
HE SAYS YEAH, I UNDERSTAND THAT
BEING A MAN COMES WITH CERTAIN
BENEFITS, ESPECIALLY IN THE
WORLD OF POLITICS.
YOU DON'T HEAR PEOPLE
COMPLAINING ABOUT HIS VOICE.
>> Dana: HE HAD RECENTLY DONE
SOMETHING PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
HE RAISED TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NOT NECESSARILY ALL FROM
TEXAS.
GAVE TED CRUZ A RUN FOR HIS
MONEY.
TED CRUZ BEAT HIM HANDILY BUT HE
ACTUALLY HAD THAT.
WHAT'S THE REASON, HE GETS ON
THIS "VANITY FAIR" COVER, LET
THEM RIDE AROUND WITH YOU LIKE
HE DID.
IT WASN'T ALL BLOWING.
>> Greg: "VANITY FAIR," I
DON'T THINK THEY WOULD DO THAT
KIND OF THING WITH THE
CONSERVATIVE UPSTART.
>> Dana: WITH THEY HAVE DONE
IT WITH KAMALA HARRIS?
>> Jesse: I THINK BETO IS
GOING TO SELL MORE MAGAZINES
THAN KAMALA HARRIS.
HE IS DREAMING.
HE'S GOT THE SHIRT.
THE SAME SHIRT EVERY SHOT.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE NEW
KENNEDY AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO PROPEL HIM INTO
AN OBVIOUSLY IT FIZZLED OUT.
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND.
SHE IS BLAMING HER BOWL PULL
NUMBERS AND FAILING CAMPAIGN ON
GENDER BIAS.
BUT SHE IS CALLING THE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS SEXIST BECAUSE
SHE'S BELOW 3%.
>> Katie: VETS BY THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAS SO MUCH LEVERAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PRIMARY
WITH ALL THESE CANDIDATES EATING
EACH OTHER LIVE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DO ANY OF THIS
WORK IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING AND MAKING NONARGUMENTS.
THE REASON WHY KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND IS AT THE BOTTOM GOES
BACK TO THE INAUTHENTIC THING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLICY
POSITIONS SHE'S PUT FORWARD IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTIONS SHE'S
BEEN ASKED AT TOWN HALLS OR IN
HER VIDEOS OR SHE'S LIFTING
WEIGHTS AND DOING THESE THINGS,
TRYING SO HARD, PLAYING BEER
PONG.
INSTEAD OF BEING AUTHENTIC AND
NOT CHANGING HER POSITION.
SHE USED TO BE FOR I.C.E., NOW
SHE'S AGAINST.
SHE IS TO BE PRO-NRA, NOW SHE'S
ANTI-NRA.
SHE HAS BEEN ABLE TO EXPLAIN WHY
IN A COHERENT WAY THAT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE PANDERING.
SHE HAS CHANGED HER POLICY
POSITIONS IN SUCH AN EXTREME
FASHION.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SHE'S
DEVELOPED A CLEAR MESSAGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MESSAGES
FROM HER CAMPAIGN.
I CAN PICK THE OTHERS BUT NOT
HERS.
TO GET BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
SEGMENT WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOCIALISM, I FIND ITSELF
STRIKING THAT THEY SAY YEAH, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL SOCIALISTS.
I'M THINKING REALLY, WHO?
ARE YOU SAYING KAMALA HARRIS IS
A SOCIALIST?
>> Jesse: SHE SAID SHE WANTED
TO DESTROY PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT SOCIALIST TO
SAY THAT WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOW TO DELIVER QUALITY
HEALTH CARE TO MORE AMERICANS.
SHE'S NOT A SOCIALIST.
>> Jesse: SOME OF THEIR
POSITIONS ARE SOCIALISTIC.
>> Juan: IT'S AN EFFORT BY
PEOPLE IN TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO GET
AWAY FROM TALKING ABOUT REAL
IDEAS FOR REAL SOLUTIONS AND
IT'S A GET AWAY FROM TRUMP'S
FAILED PROMISES ON THE WALL,
HEALTH CARE, INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Greg: DANA IS ROLLING HER
EYES.
>> Dana: I AM BREATHING DEEPLY
DEEPLY.
WHAT IS THE DEAL IN POLITICS?
YOU TRY TO DEFINE YOUR OPPONENT
EARLY.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO DEFINE
PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, FOR ALL THE THINGS.
YOU COULD LIST THEM.
>> Greg: INSANE, UNSTABLE.
>> Dana: THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
DOING THAT NOW TO THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEY LEFT THEMSELVES OPEN TO
THIS CRITICISM.
>> Juan: BUT IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Greg: WHY DID THAT MATTER?
>> Juan: I TAKE YOUR POINT.
>> Jesse: IF YOU SUPPORT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND COMPASS GAIN
PEOPLE'S PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE AND GIVING IT TO THE
GOVERNMENT, GUN CONFISCATION,
RAISING TAXES.
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS ARE
SOCIALIST POLICIES.
YOU MIGHT NOT AGREE ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE SELLING IT BUT THE
POLICIES.
>> Juan: ONE LAST POINT.
WE ARE ON A DAY WHEN TRUMP HAS
SAID I WAS GOING TO GET YOU A
DEAL WITH CHINA.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
NO, NO.
TARIFFS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THOSE.
>> Katie: CAN YOU DEFINE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN DEMOCRATIC